bonsoir et bienvenue pour le journal en
ce 4 février 2015 et dans l'actualité
yvelinoise aujourd'hui le président du
Conseil constitutionnel est état
Versailles hier soir pour participer ou
rencontre du Jeu de Paume un rendez-vous
public lancés l'an dernier par France
Culture et le château de Versailles un
collectif regroupant une quinzaine de
salles de spectacles dans les Yvelines
interpellent les élus suite aux
difficultés financières des
collectivités territoriales et leurs
incidences invités en plateau tout à
l'heure présidente et vice-président du
réseau créative et puis Pauline et
Clément II Guyancourtois viennent de
quitter la France le couple va traverser
l'Amérique du Sud pendant 8 mois nous
les avons rencontrés juste avant le
départ le préfet des Yvelines tient en
ce moment mercredi soir une conférence
de presse afin d'évoquer la question de
la radicalisation religieuse il y aurait
dans le département une centaine de cas
préoccupants déjà signalés le préfet qui
reconnaît que les Yvelines sont un
département avec un fort Hérault de
djihadiste s'il n'y a pas de profil type
le problème et surtout présent dans les
zones urbaines avec un passé
d'immigration musulmane comme le taux
d'agglomération de 50 ans ou encore Val
de Seine une structure départementale
pour prévenir les risques a été mise en
place depuis mai dernier plus de détails
dans notre prochaine édition demain dès
18h
et puis suite à l'agression de 3
militaires en faction devant un centre
communautaire Juifs de Nice le président
du Conseil général des Yvelines pierre
bédiat réagi ce matin l'auteur des faits
Moussa Coulibaly est originaire de
Mantes-la-Jolie et pour l'élu
départementale cela porte atteinte aux
efforts des mosquées nantaises mentaises
qui travaillent avec les institutions de
la République pour lutter contre toute
radicalisation le parquet antiterroriste
et maintenant saisi de la faire le
domicile Yves Linois du suspect a été
perquisitionné hier politique et
Jean-Louis Debré qui était ce mardi à
Versailles le président du Conseil
constitutionnel était l'invité de France
Culture dans le cadre de l'émission
rencontre du jeu de paume et quel est le
rôle méconnu de ce Conseil
constitutionnel j'ai envie Debré a
répondu aux questions de Mélanie poquet
et de Michael et midoro
puisque le rôle du Conseil c'était
l'événement ce mardi à Versailles
Jean-Louis Debré président du Conseil
constitutionnel était invité par France
Culture dans l'émission rencontre du Jeu
de Paume un rendez-vous programmé dans
l'enceinte historique Versailles l'homme
politique français ministre de
l'Intérieur entre 1995 et 1997 président
de l'Assemblée nationale de 2002 à 2007
est revenu à cette occasion sur les
actions et les fonctions du Conseil
constitutionnel
il est là pour garantir
la Constitution mais surtout le
préambule de la conscience 58 qui
renvoie à la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen
le 1789 et qui renvoie aussi au
Préambule de 1946 les droits et les
libertés telles que les républicains
telles que les hommes du 23 juin 1789
l'ont voulu la liberté d'opinion la
laïcité la liberté d'expression toutes
ces libertés qui sont dans la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et
citoyens la liberté d'association
et bien d'autres et bien la mission du
Conseil concerne et de les faire
respecter
je suis une juridiction indépendante je
juge la loi soit quand elle est déférée
par les parlementaires le président de
la réplique le Premier ministre ou le
président des assemblées soit ce qu'on
appelle la question prioritaire de
conserveté lorsque des justiciables et
bien contestent à l'article de loi du
mois ils peuvent dans certains
conditions nous saisir
nous avons annulé une loi de
1831 ou 38 qui était l'hospitalisation
sans consentement et qui avait été à toi
qui avait fait que Camille Claudel la
mise de Rodin avait été hospitalisée
pendant 30 ans nous avons annulé les
tribunaux maritimes qu'ils a-t-elle
Colbert parce que la composition du
tribunal il y avait des gens qui
n'étaient pas des juges fonctionnaient
pendant des siècles mais chaque fois
nous revisitons nous ne pouvons pas le
saisir mais à la demande de justiciable
ou de représentants de l'État ou de la
nation nous revisitons nos droits et nos
libertés et nous regardons si ils ont
été respectés
écoutez c'est une toute petite équipe
puisque le Conseil conditionnel c'est en
tout de
du personnel d'entretien au président 60
personnes quand je suis arrivé le
Conseil rendait 16 décisions par an nous
aurons 250 avec
9 huit membres 9 8 9 avec moi qui sont
là et qui tous les jours juge les
recours qui sont déposés par nos
concitoyens d'une durée de 9 ans le
mandat de Jean-Louis Debré à la tête du
Conseil constitutionnel s'achève en 2016
Jean-Louis Debré qui a également réagi à
l'affaire qui entoure Jean-François Copé
hier l'ancien président de l'UMP a été
mis en examen pour Rabut de confiance
par les juges financiers c'est derniers
en quête vous le savez sur le paiement
du parti et des pénalités qui avaient
été infligées à Nicolas Sarkozy après la
campagne présidentielle par le Conseil
constitutionnel on écoute Jean-Louis
Debré à ce sujet je ne m'inscris pas
aujourd'hui dans l'actualité je suis
appelé à devoir de réserves et donc je
ne parle pas de la politique je ne fais
pas de politique je ne fais plus de
politique je juge les droits et les
libertés
avant de parler culture dans un instant
et des inquiétudes des salles de la
région sur leur financement nous allons
voyager deux Guyancourtois ont quitté la
France ce matin destination de Buenos
Aires muni de leur sacs et de leur vélo
se coupent à décider de traverser
l'Amérique du Sud pendant huit mois un
antidote efficace contre le stress
urbain mais surtout l'occasion
d'utiliser un transport écologique et
convivial reportage William elle
donc voilà Buenos Aires Santiago la
passe en Bolivie Lima au Pérou qui
tourne Équateur Bogota et Carthagène en
Colombie
562 km à parcourir en vélo c'est le
projet fou de Pauline et Clément tout de
travailler dans le marketing et après un
an de préparation ils n'ont pas hésité à
quitter leurs emplois pour réaliser
leurs rêves le but c'est vraiment de
faire une coupure de faire une sorte
d'année sabbatique et de se et de un peu
de faire le projet de vie quoi quelque
chose qu'on fera certainement jamais
jamais de nouveau et donc d'en profiter
au maximum et d'en tirer le maximum le
genre de projet qu'on pourra raconter
quand on aura 70 ans aux petits enfants
enfin voilà c'est clair que c'est une
fois dans une vie
trust ce sera la devise de ce couple de
baroudeur pour ces prochains mois et
pour se faire connaître ils ont même
créé un site internet une occasion de
suivre leur périple
c'est de promouvoir cette usage autour
de nous en parlant en parlant de ce
qu'on vit sur notre blog et donc que
tout le monde puisse le suivre et aussi
en essayant un peu de dresser une sorte
de panorama de l'usage du vélo qui est
fait en Amérique du Sud une initiative
saluée par plusieurs entreprises qui
sponsorisent une partie de leur matériel
cette petite balise spot donc il va
rassurer nos parents pendant les huit
mois donc en fait c'est un GPS satellite
où on a juste appuyer sur un bouton et
ça permet d'envoyer nos coordonnées
d'attitude longitude à une à une chaîne
de mails qui alimentera aussi sur notre
site internet donc voilà même si on est
paumé au milieu du désert nos proches
seront est-ce qu'on se trouve à quelques
heures du départ Pauline et Clément
vérifient une dernière fois leur
équipement un peu de stress mais surtout
une grande fierté car demain ils seront
les ambassadeurs du cyclotourisme
culture jusqu'au 8 février l'espace de
Coville à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
accueille l'exposition conjointe de
Béatrice Levoyer sculptrice et claire de
la Varenne une peintre une solide amitié
artistique unissait de femmes Catherine
sulato pour ce reportage sur des images
de David charpentier
l'une est sculptrice l'autre peintre une
solide amitié inhibéatrice le voyait
éclaire de la Varenne la première est
d'abord historienne avant de se former à
la peinture sur des corps et de réaliser
des trompe l'oeils et des trompeurs
devenus des sculptures j'ai toujours été
très attiré par l'être humain dans
toutes mes études d'histoire ce qui
m'intéressait c'était beaucoup plus la
vie de l'homme à travers à travers
l'histoire donc à travers les guerres
etc et autres c'était pas du tout le
plan stratégique Béatrice le voyez
mettent en scène des tableaux de la gare
de 1870 réalisé par l'un de ses ancêtres
Alphonse de Neuville c'est d'ailleurs
l'une de ses réalisations qui touchent
le plus clair de la Varenne j'aime
énormément tout ce qu'elle a tiré des
tableaux d'Alphonse de Neuville j'aime
énormément toute la vie qu'il y a de ces
petites scènes tout ce que elle dit sur
l'humanité de ses soldats et puis aussi
il y a tout un souci du détail car de la
Varenne elle a fait l'école du Louvre si
elle parle aussi bien de son ami c'est
que la aussi a le sens du détail elle
aurait aimé être conservatrice de musée
et c'est finalement dans les tableaux
anciens qu'elle puisse en inspiration
c'est la restauration de tableaux qui
m'a donné envie de me mettre à la
peinture j'avais toujours beaucoup
dessiné j'ai toujours aimé faire des
portraits et puis là j'ai eu envie de me
mettre à la peinture ça fait une
peinture qui paraît très très ancienne
mais je me dis aussi que ce qu'on peut
voir dans beaucoup d'expositions
aujourd'hui ça existe déjà depuis 100
ans alors après tout pourquoi s'inspirer
d'oeuvre qui ont 100 ans ou bien de 100
ans ou bien 300 ans et c'est mon univers
aussi les deux femmes se côtoient très
régulièrement depuis 10 ans elles
exposent pour la cinquième fois ensemble
on s'apporte toutes les deux un regard
très différent elle vient d'un monde de
l'École du Louvre elle est extrêmement
cultivée au niveau artistique moi je le
suis très peu au niveau artistique en
revanche je venais du monde de la
peinture en décor donc plus technique
plus que jamais à côté plus artisan et
les deux se sont rejoints et donc on
s'apporte mutuellement un regard
un regard neuf et quand on demande à
Béatrice de choisir un tableau de Claire
elle préfère s'orienter vers un paysage
c'est peut-être la son petit tableau
d'une saynète
c'est une forme très allongée donc
j'aime ce côté
moins classique c'est un paysage
extrêmement harmonieux ce qui est la
caractérise beaucoup claire une double
exposition et une amitié artistique à
découvrir jusqu'au 8 février à l'espace
de Coville à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
on reste dans la culture pour ce journal
une quinzaine de théâtres de villes du
département des Yvelines réunies au sein
du réseau créative interpelle les élus
sur leurs difficultés financières on va
en parler avec sa présidente Sabine
Caussin bonsoir vous êtes également
directrice du Théâtre du prisme et
l'encourt et Richard Letertre bonsoir
vous êtes donc le vice-président du
réseau est directeur du théâtre riddis
ESAT à plaisir aujourd'hui quelle est la
situation financière de vos salles
est-ce qu'il y a une inquiétude une
vraie inquiétude et au-delà de
l'inquiétude est-ce que ça se traduit
dans les finances est-ce que c'est
difficile actuellement alors je vais je
vais commencer à en parler et donc oui
bien sûr qu'il y en a une mais notre
démarche elle est pas attendre pour
compter les difficultés que nous avons
et elles sont réelles et je vais vous
dire mais c'est certainement parce que
nous avons analysé puisque nous sommes
14 théâtre de ville comme vous l'avez
dit nous avons une force de réflexion
nous sommes conscients que nous sommes
au coeur de la cohésion sociale que nous
sommes là pour animer un territoire et
que les élus ont une politique générale
de la culture mais que les contraintes
financières de restrictions budgétaires
de état implique des conditions
drastiques aux collectivités nous nous
donc nous sommes pour pouvoir ouvrir un
dialogue et inventer avec les élus de
nouvelles formes expérimentales alors
les difficultés oui parce qu'il y a des
salles qui se sont vues enlever leurs
programmation bien entendu il y en a
d'autres qui ont des difficultés
financières et ça se comprend très bien
parce que les collectivités ont du mal à
boucler le budget comment tout cet
écosystème arrivera-t-il à survivre à
exister c'est la question qu'on se pose
mais c'est pas tant la question qu'on
veut poser aux élus un autre démarche et
la démarche de se communiquer de presse
qui a quand même été envoyé assez
largement c'est comment nous pouvons
nous mettre à réfléchir ensemble pour
que l'habitant puisse avoir une
nourriture et qu'on puisse éveiller les
consciences qu'on puisse travailler la
liberté de penser
et des Finances si on prend des exemples
concrets par exemple sur le prisme à
Élancourt votre salle après alors sur le
prismeille en cours c'est compliqué
puisqu'ils sont en arbitrage budgétaire
donc on a du mal à avoir des réponses
précises je pense que tout ça ça se
précisera début avril mais c'est vrai
que nous ne sommes à l'abri de rien
c'est très clair on est à l'abri de rien
alors peut-être pas de trop de
conséquences lourdes mais chez nous ça
va vite dans nos économies ça va très
vite donc on pousse un bout du domino et
que tout le chemin du domino s'écroule
la situation sur plaisir par exemple
pour votre établissement pour mon
établissement c'est un petit peu
différent puisque moi je suis un
établissement à la fois médico-social et
culturelle donc j'ai d'autres sources de
financement mais c'est vrai que dans le
réseau créatif il y a énormément de
salles qui ont souffert depuis
effectivement le la problématique
politique depuis les municipales couplés
avec la problématique économique et puis
si on rajoute la réforme de territoriale
et bien problématique pour expliquer la
situation actuelle vous l'avez dit la
situation financière ça tout le monde en
est bien conscient des difficultés
économiques et puis il y a deux
changements aussi réforme territoriales
c'est-à-dire que les compétences propose
des futurs agglomérations on en a parlé
sur cette antenne avec par exemple les
50 ans en Yvelines qui va s'agrandir et
de nouvelles communes vont rejoindre 50
ans en Yvelines donc il va falloir
redéfinir les compétences la culture est
une compétence aujourd'hui de la
communauté d'agglomération si ça change
quid donc du financement pour les salles
et puis et puis également il y a eu des
changements de couleur politique dans
certaines communes comme à 50 ans en
Yvelines est-ce que ça a eu une
incidence très concrètement depuis mars
dernier l'arrivée de la droite aux
élections municipales ça fait presque un
an est-ce que ça a eu un changement pour
les fonctions du prix si je pense que
pour d'autres fonctionnements de scènes
communales comme on a beaucoup à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines aujourd'hui je
ne vois pas la différence maintenant on
est à l'aune du vote du budget 2015 où
il est clair que des problématiques se
posent mais la réforme territoriale
posée parce qu'on en parlait tout à
l'heure pose également à terme
l'effacement des départements et donc
nos structures financières enfin nos
structures de théâtre de ville sont
financés de façon transversale
c'est-à-dire il y en a qui sont financés
en conventionnement avec le département
et c'est une politique qui permet un
rayonnement et un de permettre d'aller
plus loin dans le dans les territoires
plus ruraux du département c'est
essentiel beaucoup de structures d'entre
nous sont conventionnées soit en musique
soit en écriture contemporaine la
nacelle à Aubergenville la barbacane à
Ben donc ça c'est l'état donc pour
l'instant ça ne bouge pas trop donc on a
le Paris Métropole que va-t-il avaler
que va-t-il pas absorber comment vont
vivre les territoires autour de Paris
Métropole c'est autant de questions mais
où personne ne peut répondre aujourd'hui
ni même les élus nous avons un grand
respect pour les élus parce que c'est
eux qui prônent une politique culturelle
pour les habitants et nous
professionnellement nous faisons poser
nos expertises mais ni nous nous sommes
aujourd'hui en capacité de voir clair
dans la situation
commune qui s'engage et vous puissiez
être impliqué dans les décisions qui
sont prises et expliquer aussi que votre
mission dépasse largement le cadre de la
culture c'est ça oui je pense que il y a
un effet il y a des effets de seuil et
il y a des effets de cristallisation
entre les problèmes politiques mais en
fait c'est pas tellement un ping-pong
entre droite-gauche tellement c'est
l'accumulation entre ces problèmes
économiques un problème politique c'est
problème territoriaux et puis à un
moment donné on a déjà beaucoup raclées
les fonds de tiroirs dans toutes les
structures parce que ça fait un moment
quand même que la crise économique nous
impose et que quelque part les
institutions nous imposent de de faire
attention mais on a fait attention on a
fait attention on a fait attention et
puis là il semblerait qu'il y ait un
nouveau un nouveau seuil à franchir et
ce seuil là et bien ça s'appelle aussi
un effet de seuil et c'est qu'à un
moment donné on va détricoter tout le
travail et il faut savoir que notre
travail il est à la fois sur la défense
des œuvres sur la défense des compagnies
des artistes et de l'autre côté tout le
travail d'action culturelle c'est-à-dire
ce travail de cohésion sociale de lien
social que nous menons et pratiques
amateurs les ateliers de pratiques
artistique le travail de l'éducation
nationale donc à un moment donné
en pressurant et en pressant le plus
possible on va se retrouver devant un
problème ou peut-être même les élus ne
se rendent pas compte que 1% de plus et
ça y est on descend et on se retrouve en
économie on sait très bien les effets de
seuil et les courbes à un moment donné
on devient plus on ne peut plus
fonctionner et à ce moment-là tout le
travail investi tout le travail fabriqué
va complètement disparaître uniquement
peut-être pour 10% 20%. donc il faut
discuter pour dire attention là on peut
pas descendre en dessous ou alors faut
vraiment tout revoir la limite sur les
seuils sur les différents par exemple
d'entre nous sont à la limite ce que
vient de dire Richard est très juste
alors je voulais juste attirer votre
attention sur quelque chose qui est
important on a vécu des en France un
événement dramatique tout début janvier
et on se rend bien compte que culture et
citoyenneté devrait marcher plus plus
fort ensemble or nous nous sommes de
plus en plus vend debout puisqu'on est
bien conscient ces structures
culturelles qui avons 200 000
spectateurs dans les Yvelines qui
faisons plus de 600 à 750
représentations par an on est bien bien
conscient plus toute l'action
d'éducation artistique et la relation
aux habitants que nous sommes par la
volonté des politiques locales de la
culture nous sommes là véritablement des
forces vivantes pour approfondir la
liberté de penser construire le libre
arbitre développer les consciences
de spectacle ça va au-delà de la mission
qui est mené on va juste faire une
petite pause pour notre question du jour
micro-trottoir comme chaque soir donc
dans ce journal notre question
aujourd'hui concerne forcément le
subventionnant subventionnement pardon
de ces salles de spectacle sont-elles
assez pas assez subventionnés votre
regard
assez vital et encore plus dans cette
période de crise il pourrait en donner
plus quoi
il y a certainement encore des choses à
faire très certainement et
de quelle façon ça je ne sais pas ça
manque peut-être un petit peu
effectivement que l'État devrait
peut-être aider un petit peu plus au
développement de la culture surtout
auprès des jeunes enfants je sais pas
non ce que je suis musicienne
c'est compliqué surtout pour les
conservatoires je crois je sais qu'il y
a pas mal de de problèmes en ce moment
pour les musiciens intervenants aussi
j'ai aucune idée du budget de ce que
l'État met dedans ou voilà des fois les
spectacles subventionnés
c'est pas terrible des fois
et des fois en subventionne des
spectacles qui aurait pas besoin de
l'être juste peut-être pour réagir sur
ce qui vient d'être dit sur le
subventionnement des spectacles et pour
dépasser peut-être un petit peu ça aussi
est-ce que dans votre réflexion il faut
associer les spectateurs aussi ce qu'il
faut associer aussi le citoyen pour
savoir ce que eux attendent aussi de la
place de ce que peut proposer ce que
peuvent proposer ce qu'ils attendent je
ne sais pas parce que cette phrase est
particulière elle peut être à la limite
un peu réducteur parce qu'on attend que
ce qu'on connaît mais par contre comment
les analysent leurs besoins comment les
analysent l'envie de vivre ensemble et
de faire ensemble c'est exactement la
problématique de l'après 7 janvier c'est
comment on vit ensemble et comment on
fait ensemble et nous nous sommes des
acteurs répartis sur l'ensemble du
département en plus on fait un lien
entre le rural et l'urbain là où sont
posés nos structures donc là nos
politiques parce que nous on les aime
bien les élus ont véritablement des
leviers dans la main pour pouvoir agir
or nous sommes sur des schémas qui sont
un peu anciens qui datent même quasiment
d'une croissance en expon logiciel dans
les 20 dernières années on est bien
conscient en nous qu'il y a certainement
un travail de réflexion et de réflexion
de reposer les choses à plat et nous le
demandons voilà mais on a déjà associé
le département des Yvelines à notre à
notre réflexion justement
je rajouter que il faut peut-être sortir
d'une vision
horizontale non vertical pardon pour
arriver à une version horizontale il y a
pas que la culture qui aurait les
spectacles et puis alors les spectacles
subventionnés et puis les autres et puis
de l'action culturelle et puis après des
gens qui font du social et puis des gens
qui font de je pense qu'il faut arriver
à une vision un peu globale où nous
agissons nous sommes des services de
service public nous sommes des
délégataires du service public nous
agissons pour l'ensemble et on voit bien
avec nos partenariats éducation
nationale voilà on est aussi sur le
handicap on est aussi sur donc surtout
ces domaines là il y a un travail de
réflexion à mener pour arrêter de
cloisonner et de mettre la culture dans
un endroit et veut dire bon j'ai des
problèmes de d'argent je vais enlever à
la culture et puis tout va bien aller
pour le reste donc
vous l'avez dit par exemple les
discussions sur le budget pour
l'agglomération de 50 ans c'est en ce
moment que que ça se joue juste la peau
pour conclure la discussion ce soir
est-ce que vous avez des inquiétudes
pour les prochains mois la prochaine
saison est-ce que déjà aujourd'hui vous
êtes un petit peu dans le doute alors
c'est pas une fin de nous recevoir mais
la culture elle est nationale journal
Libération a publié une carte de
difficulté ou chacun chaque lieu ou
chaque festival peut mettre elle est
réelle elle est réelle nationalement les
départements s'effacent les départements
diminuent les budgets les collectivités
sont contraints à le faire et je ne
pense que ça ne passera pour le
bien-être de la population qui est aussi
la volonté de l'élu ce pourquoi elle
s'est engagée qui est notre expertise et
volonté de travail de pouvoir se mettre
ensemble pour savoir qu'est-ce qu'on
fait c'est pas qu'est-ce qu'on garde
qu'est-ce qu'on jette c'est comment on
se transforme et on évolue pour aller
vers du plus et du vivre ensemble est-ce
que vous restez optimiste aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y a une réponse est-ce que
vous avez il faut bien sûr il faut
rester optimiste puisque on est prêt à
discuter et on veut discuter on veut
trouver des solutions et en même temps
on veut aussi prévenir attention ne
jetons pas le bébé avec l'eau du bain
parce que après on se demanderait
peut-être les doigts donc l'ensemble de
la population pourrait
à un moment donné quand ça se délite et
bien on n'arrive plus à contenir la
fuite pour en savoir
une société ne peut pas vivre sans
culture il n'y a pas de développement de
société sans culture et elle peut être
consentie et pensée dans le sens là et
pas de développement de territoire non
plus sans culture et le territoire est
au cœur des préoccupations de l'ensemble
de des institutions et des politiques
aussi le travail de ces salles sur le
travail du réseau aussi une quinzaine de
salades à travers le département il y a
un site internet qui s'est déjà affiché
à creative.eu merci à tous les deux
d'être venu ce soir sur le plateau pour
terminer ce journal à présent reportage
de Mélanie poquet durant 4 jours à un
festival d'art sacré était organisé une
exposition proposée ainsi que des contes
d'origine juive
Joseph avait une petite veste mais à
force de la mettre tous les jours elle
devint vieille
c'est l'histoire d'un vêtement qui
diminue qui diminue qui diminue jusqu'à
devenir une chanson et même sur le plan
il y a une petite morale quoi ça veut
dire que vraiment même avec rien si on
veut avoir un regard positif on peut
avoir un regard positif sur les
événements une clarinette un simple
dessin et une histoire une heure de
compte pour faire découvrir le judaïsme
à ses enfants et à leurs parents
permettre au public qui ne connaît pas
forcément le judaïsme de rentrer par le
biais du compte dans un monde
qui s'ouvre de façon spontanée avec le
compte c'est un outil qui est très
puissant qui permet à chaque spectateur
de d'être d'emblée de plain-pied avec
les protagonistes du compte
pour cet artiste classique au départ
l'art sacré et la musique juive était
une véritable découverte l'art sacré
quelque chose de
d'extrêmement puissant extrêmement
important parce que c'est une façon
c'est une forme de prière pour moi
c'est-à-dire que lorsque je prie les
psaumes avec ma clarinette et avec le
texte hébreu
je suis
prise par la musique puisque c'est la
même principe c'est l'alternance d'un
texte musical et d'un texte verbal
seulement là la musique la clarinette se
met à prier avec moi et le texte
est un texte d'une force d'une puissance
et d'une liberté qui sont stupéfiantes
et pour les enfants non seulement pour
les enfants et nous aussi les parents et
un compte avec la clarinette c'était
vraiment très très bien pour les enfants
je trouve que c'était peut-être pour les
plus petits mais voilà c'était un éveil
à la musique je trouve ça super
sur ces quatre jours de festival des
concerts du théâtre mais aussi une
exposition peinture sculpture
photographies avec pour thème la lumière
éclat de lumière c'est les uns par
rapport aux autres donc nous avons à
travers ce que nous entendons nous avons
à nous apporter les uns les autres
l'espérance qui est au fond de chacun je
crois que ce qui les a vraiment porté
d'abord c'est le thème tout simplement
ils ont travaillé sur des versets de la
Bible qui est parlé de lumière et ils
ont essayé de l'exprimer en vraiment se
donnant à leur a en fonction de ce qu'il
aurait été demandé
culture juive ou catholique 4 jours pour
découvrir que l'art sacré peut aussi
s'adresser à tous
c'est la fin de ce journal tout de suite
sur tvfiles 78 nouvelle édition de
kiosque avec Catherine zulato très bonne
soirée